oh yeah a different really simple if we
gotta begin okay
please explain Sarah for starters and
then one guy down on this luxury decides
to go out and kill house along
everything because I've kept I have
billboards
but we decided to get together with
Julian's because I have so much stuff
and you know was either you know put it
in the Attic or put it in a restaurant
or put it to somebody who really wants
it you know and raise a little money for
the Starlight foundation which is a
great foundation
baywatch was great because we got a show
was cancelled and when we were able to
buy it from the network for a dollar or
an episode we brought it back and became
the biggest show in TV history
with Guinness Book of World Records it's
David Hasselhoff I came home and showed
it to my dad I said dad you know they
wanted me to change the name Hasselhoff
I said no my goal was to make it famous
I said no I'm proud of the name hassle
we sold 11 million singles and it became
a phenomenon and the Berlin Wall
happened to come down the same year my
record was number 1 so they asked me to
sing on New Year's Eve I so only if I
can sing on the Berlin Wall celebration
and they did they said yes I did
sang to a million people now it's
difficult when five years later the
walls down
you know I haven't been fortunate enough
to do in a Grey's Anatomy or Hill Street
Blues or ER you know but I mean I did
shows of me a lot of money and made a
lot of people happy so we had a lot of
fun
come out here with big David we all die